[Music]
I felt that he was going to make some
significant changes in our system and in
the way the country was being run in the
beginning I did have my doubts about
Trump and I still do but for me Hillary
was never could never be an option the
corruption was just so much we all want
jobs because we all want everything to
get better America we need we need to
get America back with Donald Trump's
attitude where he said I'm not a
politician that's what America wanted to
hear they wanted to hear I'm not a
politician I'm a businessman and this
country right now needs a businessman
most have helped people out and you know
build that wall with everything to keep
to evil egos out of here I just don't
trust Hillary or any of her views and
hopefully Trump will come through and do
what he says this boy
[Music]
the people were working there working
but there it's called the working poor
and Obama kept it at that in the last
past ten years it's it's changed
drastically you know you have children
that are 27 28 years old still living at
home with mom and dad and that's not
what we expected it's Donald Trump did
and when we were going to really eat be
either rich or poor and no in between
[Music]
too much we're getting bombarded by too
many people too many illegals and we
need to clean up loosen County it's my
County - I hold homes here and my
children are here so and I'm an American
you know our country was built on
immigrants and it's important that we
give them a attainable path better
health care the Obamacare is no good
helpless senior citizens that a little
bit more with some more of our Social
Security money we have so much problems
here economic problems and if he could
get the economic problems where you know
the low-income people could have homes
that's what America was once about it
was about getting your little piece of
pie
[Music]